samedi 2e édition du Salon du livre de
saint-sire l'école dans un lieu
emblématique le lycée militaire avec une
programmation tourné vers les
personnages historiques qui ont
participé à son rayonnement comme Madame
de maintenant Napoléon Bonaparte et le
général Charles de Gaulle pour parler du
général de Gaulle mais surtout de la
dimension spirituelle qui était tout à
fait
intégré qui imprégnait sa personne sa
pensée son action depuis le plus jeune
âge jusqu'à sa mort d'autres auteurs
locaux ou même des DomTom étaient
conviés à ce salon pour échanger avec
leurs lecteurs les lecteurs me disent
souvent en fait que ils ont démarré mes
romans et qu'ils n'ont pas pu les
arrêter jusqu'à la fin on me reproche
parfois quelques nuits blanches et j'en
suis très
fière l'occasion aussi de visiter un
établissement rarement ouvert au grand
public je vais me promener un petit peu
dans pour découvrir le merveilleux
patrimoine saint-syien puis on a aussi
profité pour visiter l'école de saint-sy
je suis surpris et puis agréablement
surpris du décor
et c'est c'est magnifique comme comme
école d'ors et déjà la ville pense à la
3e édition de son salon du livre il
pourrait s'ouvrir l'an prochain aux
écoliers collégiens et
lycéens